By now you've been using Git to keep
track of the changes in your code.
You've been pushing it to GitHub and
have a nice timeline of
your coding journey.
[SOUND] Woah, Walter!
Looks like your head's floating
in space in a Git timeline.
Don't worry.
You're going to be moving forward,
making commits and sometimes backwards,
if you make mistakes.
You'll also be branching out, and
merging when the code is ready.
We'll make sure you
don't lose your head.
The content in this lesson will also
help you with your Git workflow by
covering some of Git's best practices
in the next project and beyond.
If you're ready to Git
started let's Git to it.